For any trait, there are usually variations.
>> So wait, are you talking about things
like eye color, like blue, green, brown, hazel.
>> Right, exactly. Eye color is an example of a single trait,
but for that one trait you can have different versions or variants;
brown, green, blue. Variation is a huge theme in this course. And
it's important to recognize that different
people have different perspectives on different variations.
>> It's true,
I guess. I've always liked hazel eyes.
>> And why have you always liked hazel eyes?
>> I don't know. I just think they're better.
>> And I guess that's sort of
what we're talking about. The word better sometimes
implies that there's a good or bad eye color to begin with. We don't really want
to do that. For the most part, good
and bad shouldn't be used to reference personal
preference. Instead, for our course, we'll reserve the
word bad only for variations of traits that
cause serious health conditions, or even fatality.
>> Fair enough. So I want to know what
you think. What traits are better or worse than
other traits? These can be physical, personality or behavioral
traits. List one in each one of these boxes.